like our Southern borders open and so
the cartels our Southern borders open
yeah we have we have uh over 3 million
people a year coming into the country
illegally so it's open does that mean
that it's open effectively yeah if you
can't stop three million people from
crossing your border you're probably
pretty open border do you have anything
to compare that to number-wise yeah so
even even uh five years ago uh the
number was down to about 2,000 people a
day which at that time wait a alltime
high is it 3 million a year over I'm
genuinely concerned because I I believe
that it was around one um it's not it's
much higher than that um but we have we
have a million legal immigrants who come
in per year which is also a shockingly
high number completely out of accord
with uh any other country on Earth and
any other time in history but we also
have many more millions of illegal
aliens Crossing into the Border per year
you can look it up is a is a nice like
uh term but I'm saying like AAL foreign
National that doesn't mean that you have
to use ter alien kind of like alien just
means a foreign National oh I mean no I
mean in the ter if you're using like a
legal alien and you want to try to like
that that's like a I don't want to say
like incorrect cuz I know you guys get
about like speech and like I know you
guys get but it's not like the term
alien is kind of like I know you talk I
know you talked about I'm not calling
them ET I know you know I'm talking I
know when you talked to Bronte you
mentioned how using the term fetus is
like dehumanizing I think using the
literal word alien is also dehumanizing
but you know alien doesn't refer to
martians alien refers to those who are
not like us of a different no it just
means Foreigner they're foreign so
they're subject to foreign governments
and they're here illegally so we say
illegal
alien you could also no a more precise
term would be illegal immigrant because
they went through the immigration
process illegally you don't have to say
they didn't go through any immigration
process that's why immigrated somewhere
they're distinct from legal immigrants
that's just say a foreign National but
there are not you know someone in
Guatemala is a foreign National but
someone who's here who border illegally
and stays in the country be an illegal
alien quick lesson about like like um
like grammar and connotation right so
like the term
blacks by our definition of what a
racial category is it is not incorrect
to call somebody a black but it is
technically incorrect to call somebody a
black cuz we it's like that's kind of
that's a word that's kind of been used
to because you don't like the word what
about whites that's also a weird term
it's like segregation error terminology
that's why I don't use whites I don't
use blacks you can say black people or
white people but if you were to look at
someone crookedly after they said Oh
Black
no one would be like oh well it's just
the correct term because yeah terms can
just like the word colored is a correct
term your skin color has color in it why
people don't really have color it's
funny cuz now the term is person of
color like people of color but but you
don't I don't like that one either I
think it's very silly I don't like that
yeah because I think you can be more
specific but the broader point that the
illegal alien thing is like you know
that the connotation of alien is like
you can you can you can give me the
dictionary definition alien I agree with
you has a negative connotation the
reason it has a negative connotation is
because it is a bad thing to cross
illegally into a country they've done a
bad thing and that's why it has a bad
reason why is it really a bad thing to
cross illegally into another country yes
it's illegal and unjust how it's unjust
to cross into another country so again
it's funny because we're going to get
back on morals if someone was like
running from the cartel and they had
like it was a family it was like uh
little some little girls some a couple
boys with them and it was a family that
run the border to escape from the cartel
but that that's not what happens they
actually you work with the cartels to
cross the border illegally because the
cartels control the entirety of the
Southern border yeah and the and the
cartels run rampant within the countries
as well so if you're trying to escape
the cartel and the only way you you
don't escape it by Crossing illegally
across that border you have to work with
the cartels to cross illegally across do
you think every illegal immigrant is
working with the cartel yes practically
speaking yes the cartels control the
entirety of the Southern border and so
they off the cartel and then they end up
in a type of wait so after they after
they cross over do you think that
they're still working with the cartel or
do they work with the they owe them a
lot of money they owe them a lot all the
illegal immigrants owe them a lot of
money and they're working with the
cartel yeah they can you state that I
can't that that's how they end up in
prostitution which was how we got on
this topic because of modern day sex
slavery or they end up running drugs or
they end up in other criminal
Enterprises for the cartel well first
first who do you think controls the
Border firstly firstly um do you think
that prostitution is only a thing that
is brought into America through the
southern border no but like ilal like
sex slavery do you think that's only
exclusively done by non-americans no of
course not so why do we keep why do we
keep like making this assumption like
okay I ask I I ask you to substantiate
that every illegal immigrant that
crosses the border is nowel secretly
working with the
cartel and open yeah so and it's funny
because doesn't even need to be cartel
they can just pay coyotes who are
trained at running people across workel
they at times but that doesn't mean that
the people then work for the coyotes
that then work for the cartel do you
think the cartels just let these people
off the hook out of the goodness of
their heart they fer them acoss do you
think that they have do you think that
the cartel has a database of the 3
million illegal immigrants that come
across the American think they keep
track do you think they they keep they
keep track of them they have more
tracking they have more tracking
capacity than the United States
government who lost people's parents
under Donald Trump when they locked them
in cages when they locked them they did
it's literally an image uh so when it
comes to illegal aliens yes the cartels
actually are better at keeping track of
people but but two than the United
States government yeah because the US
government just releases them into the
country but because that's a an
intentional policy of Democrats I'm I'm
but but do you know what I'm confused at
like how your worldview ends up like on
it so it's an intentional policy of was
that kind of like Grace great
replacement esque you what do you mean
by great replacement like the the theory
that um Democrats or political people
are like deliberately conspiring to
bring to import more people different
they say that they say that they're
doing that who there was a a major study
that came out in 2004 that shaped the
political campaign even of Barack Obama
who described the Coalition of the
ascendant you've seen a columns like
this in the New York Times by Michelle
Goldberg about how the Democrats need to
import more foreign people and that will
help the Democrat political coal I don't
think there's any source that you could
find me out there that says that the
Democratic party has said that they need
to import more foreign people if you're
saying that they they appeal more to the
values of of immigrants they would want
to they would want to I think seen on B
policy they favor much higher level
immigration and amnesty for illegal yeah
they favor a lot more levels of
immigration because immigration helps
the country that doesn't mean that
they're saying we how does it help the
country it raises rates of crime it
raises rates ofy on government programs
first generation immigrants commit way
less crime than native born population
that is is true you want me to look it
up for you of illegal immigrants huh
yeah any IM imigrants illegal no no not
any not any of any and ille that's the
KE okay I can look up illegal for you
too okay that's good there there are
some good studies to this effect uh
Center for immigration studies has some
good ones out there about how uh illegal
aliens are significantly more likely to
uh be on welfare programs when they come
over here and how illegal aliens are uh
more likely to commit crimes as well and
this is especially focused in the Border
towns uh in places like Texas and
Arizona and Southern California um
illegal well I know that you brought the
the welfare issue something about
needing to something about fleeing
somewhere and you don't really have
anything left could end up putting you
on even then a lot of times you're
talking about political Asylum huh like
seeking like no no Asylum is a
completely separate process but I'm
saying if you're going to run away from
your country and come to another country
illegally a a lot of immigrants are
hesitant and even getting on that point
and B they still pay taxes to their
wages so tax I'm pretty sure there's
there's data that they I'm pretty sure
that data out there suggests that they
actually pay more into uh welfare that
they actually get back because they're
not there's something about being like
there's something about illegally being
in a country that's going to not put you
first in line to be under a government
assistance program in case they you know
find out that you're no it's not true
but you we this is why we have the
concept of sanctuary States and
Sanctuary cities this is why Gavin
Newsome in California says we're going
to be a sanctuary State this is why New
York said please bring all the
immigrants here until the immigrants
caused a lot of problems in those cities
so that that all happens and the
Democrats are pretty explicit about it
uh Democrats are explicit about but
favoring High yeah higher levels
favoring a higher level for the ones
here yeah yeah so am I favoring a higher
level it's politically advantageous but
it's socially destructive so there's a
difference between it's also bad for the
people who cross there's a difference
between saying I want more immigration
in my I want more immigrants in my
country because uh I want to we should
appeal more to them and they can help
our country and they we want amesty for
them there's a difference between saying
that and saying we are going to
deliberately import people to replace a
white population that's the great rep
what do you mean to rep like you're
going to shove it more brown people that
you bring in the less they breed they
breed with the people in the country and
then the concept of whiteness gets like
more and more deteriorated till there's
not as many white people that's the
great replacement yeah that's what I
asked you about you said well yeah the
Democrats are deliberately and you
they're deliberately flooding the
country with migrants that's true I mean
but they well by not enforcing their
border polic how are they not enforcing
the Border you Jo Biden allows 3 million
people to come into the country so then
how many did how many did Donald Trump
allow because Joe Biden's immigration
policy has been mostly similar to Donald
Trump the the numbers were much lower
under Trump and the numbers in the first
months of Trump's presidency illegal
immigration collapsed now at six months
out into the rest of Donald Trump's
Administration the numbers started to
jump back up again but the reason for
that is because the Democrats styed him
on building the border wall and styed
him on on Ice deporting illegal aliens
and made a big haloo about uh Donald
Trump putting families in cages cages
that were built by Barack Obama Barack
Obama did not build those cages he did
no he did
there's a there's a completely proc
literally didn't that's literally just a
lie I mean I I think we can get away
with lying when you couch it the cages
built I'm not sure exactly what year
they were built they were not built by
Barack Obama well he didn't physically
build themra okay yeah I'm saying that
that the whole concept of the cages
being used to contain these migrants by
the way telling you when they were built
you tell me when they were built you're
just insistent that I'm not right about
I'm saying when you say that the cages
were built by Barack Obama first of all
I have no evidence that
his administration constructed the cages
and even if they did construct the cages
they were not used as cages for people
you do understand that right the whole
reason why the whole reason why the
Democrats made a big hullo about
containing people in cages is because a
bunch of migrants were coming across the
border and then the Trump administration
were shoving them in cages there was no
distinction between whether or not they
were applying for Asylum which the UN
said that we violated international law
on that front you can roll your eyes
about international law but the process
because the process EC how do you know
that because we have we have 60 years of
data migrants they're majority vast
majority economic migrant yeah you can
say a lot of them are economic migrants
but have no way of knowing that if you
stop them as soon as they come across
the border and throw them in a cage the
legal process that we agreed to on a
national front is when someone is
declaring asylum in a country they go
across that border go to the nearest
station and they declare their thing for
Asylum and then they get Refuge while we
await the process what do you think the
cages are though it's not like literally
a dog cage it's it literally looks like
a dog cage and they had foil blankets
they lit you can Google pictures of it
you get sure they didn't throw him in
they didn't throw him in a Rottweiler
cage but
they because there were millions of a
processing center what processing were
they going through they lost people's
parents they were sitting there there
were disease breaking out there was foil
blankets there was really child just
died under the Biden Administration in
the same issue but of course it the
media never made a big a big deal about
it because say actually if you well I
mean if you've been paying attention
Biden has been having a lot of criticism
about how his immigration policy like I
said has not been that different I don't
I don't see the crying AOC photos like
we saw under Trump furthermore though
want do you think AOC is supposed to go
to the border and take a separate
picture under every president about no I
think it was I think it was a cynical
Ploy and she wasn't even near the
centers when she did it she was she was
outside of a fence and posing for a
picture but even even beyond the the
processing of these people there there
was a a survey that came out from fusion
and uh Amnesty International reported in
The Huffington Post so we're talking
about liberal organizations what
percentage of illegal alien women and
girls who cross that border illegally do
you think are raped or sexually
assaulted I'm not sure the the number is
between 60 and 80% which gets to exactly
what we were talking about uh when we
were discussing the cartel so this is a
terrible um in 2018 the illegal
immigrant criminal conviction rate was
782 per 100,000 illegal immigrants
535 per 100,000 legal immigrants and
1,422 per the one per 100 native born
Americans that is double illegal
immigrants um According to which this is
according to the KO Institute study well
that's K Institute it's a pro migration
think tank but what where where what is
their data set it's libertarian what
what what is where's their data set from
well I guess they they've conducted
multiple studies on the topic of
immigration through I just be kind of
curious to dig into those data you can
look it up this it's not even just KO I
can find you another one there is no
there is no data that you will find out
there that says that illegal or legal
immigrants commit more crime Focus
specifically on illegal here and I think
we could illegal either illegal does not
commit un unless even if you count the
one crime of crossing the border
illegally pry yeah but you still don't
get to the native born population of
course you would because then 100% of
illegal aliens would have committed a
crime but but to your point and this is
where some of these numbers get a little
fuzzy which is why the data are hard to
get here they're not convicted because
they're not processed because they're
operating outside of the the standards
of the law and they're doing that
because the political leadership in this
country wants to keep them that way
because they think it gives them
political Advantage M um um I was
looking at uh I'm sorry I apologize that
I didn't necessarily hear everything
that you said because I was trying to
look at the uh Scientific American find
you some other data about the crime
statistics I didn't know they were
immigration experts over there at
scientific America you can analyze data
they talk about uh you can that's a
that's a sociological study if you're
trying to analyze the behavior of people
and the likelihood to commit crime
that's so look I have no doubt that that
uh leftwing and libertarian groups want
to make Scientific American is a
leftwing group now yeah yeah yeah
I guess if we're then editorial bias it
does I mean well I mean I could you
could you could go to Scientific
American and you could take issue with
methodology you're debunking but if
you're just going to say well it's left
wing no I'm just saying it it hasn't it
does have an editorial perspective which
is leftwing but and and it's kind of
silly that well the editorial yeah yeah
an editorial perspective where it's like
what articles that you're talking about
on like given topics it could be but if
the data data then the data is I think
that that's kind of my point though is
the notion that Scientific American
would be publishing a study on US
immigration policy Poli when you say
Scientific American do you think that
Scientific American is just like we put
a chemical in a beaker and then this is
what we yeah well initially were focused
on Natural Science notra sociology is a
science well it's a it's or social
sciences are like like when you talk
about um when you talk about statistics
and uh how those apply to by that
standard all observational studies right
huh by that standard all of politics is
a science